welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast this week i
had the fantastic mitchell franklin join
me in the studio to discuss his
recruitment journey he joined a company
called signify and very quickly climbed
the ranks was the first person in that
business to invoice for a million pounds
and in the last year he's actually gone
on his own recruitment journey and built
his own business we talked about crack
in the u.s we talked about developing
culture and we really uncovered mitch's
mindset which really has helped him get
to the top enjoy the episode mitch
welcome to the podcast thanks for having
me mate like we said before it's been a
long time coming a long time coming yeah
obviously when um when we first spoke it
was in the us what part of the us was
you're in l.a l.a yeah back and forth
but yeah yeah yeah so obviously spoke to
you there when you worked for your
previous company
and um we fought obviously
year into you having your own company
probably perfect time to sit down and
reminisce
talk about what you've learned
challenges
but obviously where where we wanted to
start was just talking about the
trajectory of signifying and how you
sort of climbed the ranks came in top
performer there so
if we start there and then we'll we'll
definitely focus on the yamata piece but
i want to always kick this off with the
million pound question
which is uh which i'm sure you've
thought even more about now since you've
been since you've been building your own
business but
would love to hear your thoughts on what
you really believe are the
characteristics and traits of a highly
successful high performing modern day
recruiter well i said it's a million
pound question if anyone had the answer
he'd literally sell it for a million
couldn't you tour these companies
but i think the answer isn't as simple
as these are the traits i think it's got
to be what recruiter do you want to be
because if you want to be if you wanna
hit your target just work hard like you
don't need anything else yeah in my
opinion yeah your target by pure hard
work
you want to do more than your target
you'll have a belief system you've got
to be curious you've got to work build
better relationships you have and most
importantly accountability to go above
and beyond your target you've got to
start taking responsibility for yourself
but it depends how far you want to go
right like i've always had expectations
for myself and for our team as well and
um yeah i think
take out everything else so you can you
can get by by sheer hard work nothing
else matters so what what have ended up
been some of the characteristics or
things that you've typically tried to
look for in people the curiosity yeah
because i don't think you can teach that
i know it's probably a whole other
podcast about the educational system but
um people don't get taught how to think
it's like what to think so like you need
to find people that have that naturally
because they don't get taught that when
they're younger so it's like you can
find people that have navigated their
way through life learning how to think
themselves
put them in a recruitment environment
and they become a consultant rather than
a talent scout or whatever else like
they consult with from day one even with
a talent scout title so that naturally
the curiosity
continue desire to learn and
i've come back to that accountability
all the time because like no one's gonna
no one's gonna build for you i think
right now and again i did get the odd
flick on but um like to get someone
going but you can't build a career off
that i need to be accountable for how
late you stay how many hours you put in
how many hours you're working your days
off yeah so curiosity
always willing to learn and then the
accountability i love that 100 so who
who or curious like who was who was
mitch before recruitment then so did you
work in um property yeah so yeah who
obviously you said you've always had
high expectations and stuff but who was
mitch before recruitment so i never
wanted to get into business you never
wanted to get into business i never
wanted to work in an office never wanted
anything like that why what did you run
i wanted to be an raf pilot oh wow yeah
um my eyes weren't good enough no i
dislocated my knee oh wow yeah two weeks
before the really first yeah oh so yeah
done that was like proper the dream
basically it was four years old yeah
really yeah where'd that come from just
i got given a plane when i was four when
i was on holiday bought my land she gave
me a little plane yeah i was obsessed
with it really and for me it was like
the only job for me yeah and then i was
working on the golf course at the time
yeah and that was plan b it's like if i
don't be a fire pilot i'll go travel
around the world
being a green keeper which is to this
day my favorite job green keeper yeah
wait so so that's basically just cutting
the grass really
yeah why is it why is it why is that i
love it i've played golf since i've been
at 11. okay and uh yeah i mean it's
perfectionist you know like we took the
golf course to number one in the county
like since i was there by cutting grass
yeah i was um i was only 16 and i got
put in charge of a few people there and
i was like yeah like this is a real
passion and like now i'm looking at
houses for myself like me and my partner
looking into like walking wardrobe and
all this stuff number yeah just big
guard and
i'm gonna stripe it perfectly
really yeah like i'm obsessed with it oh
that's so interesting um but yeah so
when did the first like busy yeah like
visit like so the knee was the knee went
i tried really yes yes so i thought what
we gotta do now and when it was in
school i was like made a lot of money
like i actually
left school i made less than i made in
school why what was you one of those
guys that sold up rented out three
lockers had a whole lot really full
operation
because i hated school hated it yeah
yeah yeah
i think everyone like everyone's got
there was one or two people in their
school year that was the person that had
the sweets
really wow that guy and i had a wicked
relationship with the teachers even
though i didn't like it like i was good
you know like i didn't [ __ ] around i was
a good kid and because of that i
leveraged those relationships and i lost
stepped out of class and i needed to go
and sell something yeah
where did that come from
um just i think i've always been like
independent like i've never wanted to
take anything from anyone i've always
wanted to do my own thing okay and i was
sitting in school bored out my mind it
was a combination between what i wanna
and i always like motorbikes my dad
would never let me have one okay so i
was able to buy myself if i have to so i
started asking for a twenty pound loan
put a full powerpoint presentation
together about how i'm going to repay
him and he took me to costco bought 20
pounds worth of staff and yeah from that
paid him back and a bit more and uh
scaled it up for four years four years
yeah done it from your eight to year ten
to yeah
yeah
you can make some serious bank done that
i always think that i was making after
across like fifty six months a day which
is really as a decent as a 13 14 year
old all right
um so soon as soon as the knee happened
i was like right like i can't do what i
really want to do yeah i can't follow my
passion just make make money just go for
it so yeah and so they ended up in
property base
yeah by mistake as well really yeah i
wanted to get into marketing okay and
then i went for an apprenticeship scheme
didn't get the job i got we did got
didn't get like four jobs that went for
really yeah yeah so like that whole
story but i've never been rejected like
i hear what people say it's like not my
story like yeah yeah pick no one would
have me and i think that's because i was
coming from the golf course like no one
was interested in taking like
this guys this guy's been cutting grass
yeah exactly so no one would give him a
shot but then um i had an estate agency
reach out because i was on like the
apprenticeship yeah like scheme and he's
apparently he just saw my name and
really wanted to reach out i chatted
with him and he brought me in as an
apprentice
cheap labor in that yeah i took less
money again
i took i made less money when i left
school
to work on the golf course and i made
less money leaving the golf course to go
and probably yeah but um i'm a big
believer in taking a step back to go
forward and go forward yeah i've always
done that so how um how did you did you
ended up like selling a property to a
recruiter or something like that how did
the recruitment piece happen no so i was
it was all right i enjoyed it um i was
in sales first and then
this guy bought a house in cash okay um
and he sent me his ftfc proof of funds
he had 1.5 million that right and i'm in
the wrong job
yeah what i want to be buying these
houses not selling them so um i
transitioned to latins anyway
manage the office
um and then i was just there just sort
of like this is this i'm pretty much
done here i spoke to the director about
opening new offices and stuff and he was
so 50 50 about it i was like i can't
wait around forever
um then dubai come around opportunity oh
he went to dubai yeah never heard of
dubai before like would you get sort of
that closer like the veer group thing uh
no it was just a real estate agent all
right 200k earning potential but it's
like a commission out of commission
actually yeah salary that's a lot of
people did i wasn't 18 at the time wow
it went over yeah well i've never heard
of it within 60 days i was in dubai by
myself yeah how was that then
yeah
yeah real hard really yeah that's tough
mission only and obviously i was only
18. the most amount of savings in the
world by this point yeah but i had
enough someone over there about nine
grand of savings yeah literally i've
never really spent anything so that she
went over there yeah my dad offered me a
safety net which was nice like i knew
i'd be all right if i needed a little
bit i didn't want to take it yeah i went
over there
met a guy that we started with uh ewan
and he's probably like one of the
biggest figures in my life now like he's
five six years older than me
hardest work i've ever worked with
really like if he joined new matter
today like i'd love it really but he's
retired now yeah
retired left dubai he's back in the uk
doing property doing hmos so so how long
was you therefore yeah just over a year
okay yeah got that yeah that must have
been some serious grounding i've never
seen i was to this day like like the
most resilient sales people i've worked
with like the whole setup there just
provided high performance
and the people that didn't cut it just
got left out to dry yeah the business
model was exceptional i feel like it
could have been done a little bit
differently like looking after the
people they had but they didn't need to
like they were just churning through
people i think about a person left per
week at the time yeah i know they've
taken care of this they'll just spend
three people until the the people that
are left are like performing from what i
hear they're looking after a lot of
people know a bit more and um the the
owner of it like he's a good guy like a
very good businessman i look up to him
in a bit and what i learned there was
pivotal for going into recruitment
like
so what so
so let's go into the recruitment piece
then so like was is there any story like
how you got into it then did you meet
someone or did you know you wanted to
get so there was a guy that
went to school my brother um i had him
on linkedin and he was in recruitment
and there's like it seems pretty
straightforward a lot of transferable
skills so i thought i'll look into it
um spoke to this spoke to erector wreck
he was quality just worked him
and he told me all about it and i was
like all right that's sweet when i when
i actually met him for the first time i
thought i was interviewing for their
company yeah it's so common that yeah
yeah so um start talking about the
companies met
four yeah about four companies when i
came back to the uk from dubai i also
met with an estate agency to manage
their office and it was just the same
[ __ ] like i knew i weren't right but
then i met these recruitment companies
also they weren't right
so um i only only meant to spend like
four to six months in recruitment i was
going to get out of it again i was going
to start my own property business so
recruiting was a short-term fix but i
always knew recruitment was at the heart
of um of any business so i thought let
me go into let me learn how to hire
people learn learn like work in the city
see what it's like
um and yeah i met met with five
companies four five companies
all the same like literally all the same
and then i was gonna accept one and then
dan who i was working with he said i've
got one more for you
i can set you up tomorrow morning and i
thought i've seen so many already like
it's to be another one he said let me
book it in and i was like i may or may
not go to it went to sleep that night
fully thinking i'm not going to go woke
up and i was like i'm doing nothing i'll
just go
signify
yeah yeah it's the place for me so let's
just talk about that for a second you
know when you say they're all the same
yeah what do you mean
suited and booted like big corporate
office like the white walls the blue
carpet like the just the corporate
buildings
same talk same thing same promises like
same same sort of size they were as well
like how was it going to make an impact
to this business it's already got 300
people in so who did you meet ryan yeah
uh ryan laws charlie what was that how
where was the business at when you met
them about seven people something else
oh wow okay yeah super super young yeah
it's completely different position then
yeah they've turned into their second
office so they've been at one and they
moved to their second one and uh yeah
super super early so what struck you
there then just the people that you
would immediately be able to learn
impact dubai was good right like and
i struggled into by mentally like i hit
a real lower depression because like i
went there and got everything i wanted
but i still wasn't happy okay so i knew
i had to come away and do and be part
something bigger than myself because the
body standing around two feet like yeah
there's no one else there there's no
there's no end goal like you just how
much money can you earn this month for
next month and a month after and i
didn't really give you 15.
yeah like really struggled there so when
i came back i've got to be part of
something bigger than myself
um i'm meeting these other recruitment
companies like sticking with the same
[ __ ] and that's why i was like i'll
accept one because i'm going to leave
and do my own business anyway
and i knew i weren't quite ready anyway
to start straight away like i knew i
hadn't got the leadership attributes and
stuff like that so if i need to go
somewhere and learn some stuff and then
when i met those guys i was like this is
the place where i'm going to learn all
this like these are the guys i'm going
to learn from
probably on a bit more money be a bit
more fulfilled while i'm here but yeah
it's never supposed to be a long term
i've generally fought six months max so
when you left what did the company look
like obviously we've had ryan on the pod
so like what i think that'd be good just
to get that context so like you know
about 35 people and you're in the us i
was in the u.s so i went over to the u.s
in 2019 me and charlie went over there
to open to open up their usb
yeah yeah so what what do you think
a career in recruitment has given you
then that may be least expected
um
yeah i'll fall by this question yeah
it's a tough one really because i think
a lot of people will think about like
i never expected to earn the money i did
honestly like it went above my
expectation that's changed my life and
the people around me in their life yeah
i never expected to travel so much
but for me it's like it's provided me
with like my personal life now like some
of my best friends people i've met for
recruitment like my network and my
partner like i met her on an incentive
trip really but i would have never met
her through recruitment yeah so it's
like i've got my whole life now because
i spent three years being influenced by
our career yeah that's interesting
so um remind me so was you uh so you was
at sigma five four was it like three
three years yeah it's nice so see
looking at that from what i can see you
obviously was the first person
to invoice million pounds
uh used top biller for for a year so
that's obviously what people are
interested in that's why people list
this podcast so let's why don't we just
first like let's let's think about
obviously that an amazing achievement of
being the first person and confident to
invoice the the million pound let's
unpack that a bit i guess what would you
say are some of the things that maybe if
you
in hindsight some of the things that
maybe you did differently from the
people around you that you think maybe
would have helped you got there quicker
um i just knew i was my belief system i
believe yeah yeah in my first two weeks
i was at the pub with a few of the
leadership guys and i said in in the
future like i'm going to overtake all of
you and like in a battery way but like
we had a good relationship but i meant
it as well like i genuinely believed i'd
go to the top and then we
i spent six and a bit months billion in
20 um
2018 the first year yeah and i was just
second top biller like i was just shy of
charlie charlie's my mentor and yeah i
contribute pretty much everything that i
know the foundations yeah yeah and i was
just shy of him even i was only billing
for six months really i was like we're
like 10 grand between us in that first
year
why do you think he was able to do that
though um i literally worked every day
every hour like they gave me a key to
the office really early on so i was
literally on there on saturdays like i
traveled to london i couldn't even
afford to pay for the train when i
started so i just used to jump the
barrier think about bring my little pack
lunch and i i would really i had nothing
and i was like
for me like my goals wasn't a goal it's
like it was a non-negotiable yeah like i
envisioned before i left the bar i set
up a 24 month plan okay and um at the
end of it it was like i had loads of
little goals but i had like a little
catchphrase like at the end of it i'll
be ripped and rich
like yeah it didn't work out as much as
i wanted
but um so where like have you have you
got a chip on your shoulder like have
you feel like you've got something to
prove
no not really yeah i just never want to
rely on anybody and
because i just find that because like so
a lot of people i'm sure you've sat down
with people that have said the same
things that you did but how many people
actually well
for me it's not it was non-negotiable
like i hear a lot of people say a lot of
things and it's like how much does that
really mean to you mm-hmm like is that a
must-have well i had quite a good
upbringing like we didn't have anything
when i was younger we live in a two bed
flat me and my brother my parents my dad
was a lorry driver my mom worked in a
bar just like they're never around
and uh i feel like this is not the life
i want like my parents gave me
everything and i'm so so happy for that
but
it wasn't the life i want for my future
like i want to be around i want freedom
like my dad was grafted my dad's like a
harder worker than me like graphs and
graphs and graphs you've always had that
work ethic yeah but for other people and
i'm like you'll graft him for what like
where's the end goal and i think i
remember being like young young thinking
that
so for me it's like i know what my
life's going to look like i'm very young
like i know what it's going to look like
it's completely yeah so it's like my
when i say like i was going to be top
villa i was going to build a million
like in 2019 i said to the guys i'm
going to be a million this year and
they're like no you're not like crazy
but you just had complete beliefs
how can how how do you how do you think
people can
cultivate more self-confidence and
self-belief do you think self-confidence
i wish i knew i'm not a confident person
okay i doubt myself a lot really and i
think that is probably what drives me on
because i don't know how i'm doing what
i'm doing
like i like i wish i could like give a
blueprint to our current team like guys
this is exactly what to do it's exactly
what to say but i think it's that fear
of
this could stop at any moment yeah that
i'm not going to let it like i'm not
going to take my foot off the gas it's
the momentum that's got me here and i'm
going to keep on like i could probably
i've taken like 10 holidays in my entire
career like from back at the golf course
all the way to this date now
yeah i've never i've never stopped so
let's let's go into some granular stuff
because you know this is what people
love right so let's think at the the
height of you
uh being a top performer what did people
love this right so what what did mitch's
day plan it like like what how did you
go about
um yeah achieving the the outcomes that
you set out like what did the typical
day like for mitch at the the top of
yeah um again i wish i had one for me i
come into i plan the night before yeah
what do i need to get out of tomorrow
that's gonna make me the most amount of
money okay like so i'd be looking at the
rolls who's fastest moving and what the
highest paying fees where am i gonna get
my money from and now i plan my day
based on those because i would be
different roles every month right so i
didn't have a day plan set for every day
how it looked but for me it was like a
to-do list was imperative that's how i
worked so i was like called this this
client is the fastest moving they're the
highest paid and the most proven i need
to get six seven people out into them
when i've done that and got coverage i
need to go to the next one when i've
done that i need to go win a new role
like uh when i when i was told to go do
bd i won my role within 48 hours and
placed it one and placement 40 hours
like it was just for me it was like the
non-negotiables again it's like what am
i going to do today i'm going to win a
role
i wasn't going to leave until that
happened i find that interesting because
i think early on in your career you can
some and i'm sure you've seen this where
you don't value your time and it seems
like very early on you were very commit
you you really made sure that like
that's where you spent your time was in
the best place yeah yeah i learned that
from ewan at in dubai like the guy i
lived with him for a year i said he was
a few years older he was incredible at
sales before he used to be a car
salesman he came to dubai and i was
still young i was 18 19 when i moved
there
and what i learned from him was
unbelievable like if i didn't meet him i
didn't go to dubai and i got into
recruitment i probably went to watch
some of the key things then he's
relentless relentlessly like we used to
be talk we used to make about
200 and 300 calls a day yeah he'd make
400 500. like he would be dialing like
he wouldn't even put the phone down like
he'd have the phone here and like still
he wouldn't put it down
just relentless and like he but then he
used to leave i like car five six
and i'll be like do you not think you
could even more if you stayed longer
like if i haven't got what i need to do
in eight nine hours why do i need a warm
i'm gonna get on the next one he needs
to go to the gym he needs to look after
himself yeah and he'll come out the next
day and hit it hard again okay and it
seems like he just inspired you yeah 100
100 so before before we go on to your
mata then like because i think it's
important like how what was the
experience like going to the us then
like did you before you went there let's
just get some granite stuff so before
you went there was you sort of build in
the the us business like just talk to us
a bit about that because i think that
that a lot of people as i'm sure you've
picked up on a lot of people are
currently trying to crack on with the us
to have on their business plan so before
you went over there with with signified
what did you like what sort of ground
work did you do before you went over
there so we've done nine months of
working in u.s hours yeah um and did you
have like a goal to hit before you like
you know yeah we have to do a million
million yeah a million questions so then
that would maybe i guess instill
confidence of like we'll get there yeah
and continue this building now we've got
relationships okay so did that so what
um so what was it actually like going
over there then like what maybe some of
the the challenges that maybe you didn't
expect
i think moving to any new place is never
what you expect because going a holiday
somewhere like i've been told before and
it's like but living somewhere is
completely different like having to get
a banker's check to move into an
apartment it's like it's just a whole
different world to live in so it's like
not only are you going to open a new
office with the expectation of sure this
has got to work but you're also still
it's pretty young but i'm still going
over there and charlie's young as child
is only a year or so older than me yeah
i mean who are moving over there and not
really knowing what to do where to go
for things and trying to have the weight
on our shoulders to take the business
next level because at that point when we
were moving over there like he's
obviously left now as well but we were
so indebted into the business like we
were like we were staying till the end
yeah um so we went over there with like
this huge expectation on our shoulders
um but it was good over there good
experience again but um
yeah i wouldn't have stayed there any
longer than i did this is this america's
a weird place is it a yeah fair i guess
what because i think a lot of people be
sold this opportunity right now like
anyone listening maybe is really
aspiring to be that person that goes
over to the us what what advice would
you maybe give them i guess maybe
personally i'm professionally to maybe
really consider that maybe they might
not be thinking about
uh personally just needs to think about
like where they want their life to go
yeah i was with my partner and she
waited for me in the uk yeah just like
that was a constant strains need to
think about realistically are you ready
to give up your life in the uk um and
then professionally like
you can't change what you've done what
made you successful before i've heard a
lot of stuff about going to the us doing
things differently talking to different
people saying difference
[ __ ] for me like i'll talk to a
client in the uk and amsterdam and
belgium the exact same i'll talk to them
in the u.s okay because my service is my
service and i'm going to provide results
and i know how i do that so like i'm not
going to beat around the bush just
because the u.s is a different market
like i'll be the exact same look i might
talk to someone different because
they've got a huge intelligent teams out
there so where in the uk i might talk to
director of engineering in the us i'll
talk to director of recruiting but i'll
say the same thing and i'll never try
and shy away from who we are what we do
but i think that you've got to lean into
your strengths
it's like don't go to the u.s and do
something different because you think
that's what they want it's like what's
made you successful here we'll make
successful there so
yeah 100
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincerie and sauce breaker because you
listen to this podcast you're able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with source breaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out sourcebreaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products
so let's talk about you mata then so
obviously hit the the first year
milestone recently yeah congrats on that
thank you mate so i guess let's start
then
with
like what what do you think has been
some of the
like mentally some of the shifts that
maybe you feel like you've had to make
from being a
top performer or just obviously worrying
about the the money that you're gonna
your bill and being an employee compared
to
now being a business owner you're
growing the team what have been some of
the the mindset shifts do you think
because i think a lot of people
think about setting up on their own and
have a number of concerns so what have
you i don't know how to maybe change
your mindset shifts maybe um it's people
management
yeah i'm not like i'm not the best
people manager in the world it's
something i'm always trying to work on
i'm i'm a biller and i've got a business
mind but like i'm not a people manager
so like for me to look after people to
have their problems on my shoulders and
look after that and really take that
into consideration whereas before it's
like as a team lead
we need to build more right and this is
how you're going to build more and if
you don't like it like sorry that's
that's that's the formula whereas now
it's like you've got to build more oh
[ __ ] but something's going on in your
life okay like how can we help so it's
like balancing the act now of
i have to talk to you as a ceo rather
than a team lead because a team lead if
you don't like it go talk to the ceo
right now i am your team lead ceo
colleague like i'm everything in one
it's really hard to balance that so have
you worked on that
just talking to a lot of directors
listening to a lot of other people that
are much better than where i'm at
so yeah people that i look up to have
you tried to get people in your business
that yeah could maybe get be better at
that yeah jay's wicked jay is jay's been
with me since day one
such like a people person like he'll sit
there and listen people very much more
approachable than i might be
we've recently bought stefan as well as
a senior consultant he against
attributes that i don't have
um like just all around wicked personal
things you do that intentionally
intentionally yeah like for me i know
where our business is going so
everything we do now from the branding
to the people we're bringing in it's not
for next year's plans it's for
seven eight years time i know exactly
where i want our business to be
how important is that to have clarity in
that because i think it can be obvious
you're a startup right you're on that
journey sometimes
it's it's hard to look beyond like the
challenges directly in front of you
right but how how important have you
found it to have a vision yeah 100 need
it because if you don't then there's
been critical decisions i've had to make
which i probably wouldn't have made
without knowing where i want to go okay
and uh when i spoke with farooq before
like i think about two three weeks after
launching the first question you asked
me is where do you want your business to
go and i told him like straight away
like good answer like yeah because not
many people i don't think know that and
i think before anyone starts their own
business they've got to understand that
they want a lifestyle business which is
absolutely fine like if you're going to
build for somebody else you must do it
for yourself if you're like good
if you're a little like 5 10 man company
like fair plays you but if you want to
build something big there's decisions
you've got to make early on to give
yourself the runway to do that there's
no point in me building a lifestyle
business now or building it in a certain
way for three years down the line having
to switch it like everything we do now
is for where our end goal is at
and then how how does that help like
cause that also sort of helped
when hiring and the people part because
if you sort of do would you say that
people
has helped you get people buy into that
and also when you're hiring people or
like even when people working it's
something that they can anchor to as
well as it helps on that side yeah 100
so
we have a very clear plan where we're
going and everyone buys into that and
we've got a growth plan in the business
and out of our business which sounds a
bit like that but yeah outside um like i
don't want i don't expect everyone to be
a director of umata like it's absolutely
fine like people a lot of people fall
into recruitment like a lot of our team
have never done recruitment before so
it's like you don't have to do this
forever like i hope you do like it'll be
wicked to have you here at the end but
realistically if you want to own
whatever you want to own your own brand
like even if you're a recruitment
company your own product you've got this
idea or a clothing brand whatever it is
like we'll help you do it and i know
it's like won't help turnover numbers
when we're looking in the future but if
i can look back at the last 40 people
that left over the last four years and
all of these people when they've done
their own thing i don't i don't really
care what somebody else thinks about
turnover numbers for me it's about
giving people a platform for what they
really want to do because that's all
i've ever wanted really like every
business i've been in from this agency
to the real estate to recruitment all i
wanted was to be treated with respect
and give and live a better person yeah
like i wouldn't be giving a platform for
what i want to do and that's what i'm
trying to create here and if people stay
because they feel fulfilled enough
amazing
and if people want to go and do their
own thing then i'll equally feel
inspired and very proud if they if they
go off and do their own thing no i love
that so why obviously why don't we just
very quickly think about then a lot of
people want to start their own
recruitment company and i think it's
very the typical sentence are here is
like we wanted to do things differently
right so as you said at the early part
of this conversation you met three four
companies they're all the same so what
was mitch's intention when we were
thinking about how how is your mata
going to be different like how did you
think about that and
yeah yeah well i hear that phrase a lot
like we want to be different and i don't
know what people do differently a lot to
be honest there's a few few businesses
out there that i think are really cool
and i i didn't actually come across them
until i found it's like sr2 like i
didn't know about them when i was
planning and i thought like what i
wanted to do by putting people at the
center and be responsible like i didn't
know that existed i never come across
them i've done a lot of research as well
like a lot of planning went in like i
was planning on for like a year before i
launched
um
and then i just wanted it to be like
genuinely like we're not really
inventing the world right like we're not
the recruitment recruitment we're
finding a better service but what we're
doing differently is genuinely looking
after our people okay and that's what i
think we're doing differently and that
will translate into that better service
and there's only when i launched i come
across um srt chris and i was like oh
[ __ ] like it actually works like this
because when i first died i was like god
knows it's going to work like does
putting people first actually work i'm
not sure like
and then i saw come across outside about
two months in
and that was we were getting a good we
were getting a good start
so i felt good and then i come across
these guys and i was like oh [ __ ] like
this when you say putting people first
what do you actually mean like talks
about some like what how does that
actually show up in your business like
what i suppose
that are right for our business like
there are 40 000 recruitment companies
in the uk and every time i interview
someone i share that with them that
whatever they want in a business they
can find this is how our business looks
and this is what our expectations are
and this is what you get out of it like
our ote is 100k okay just like hit your
target you're taking home six figures
yeah so like i don't know any other
recruitment company that does that so
it's like for me if you want you want
that come in and we'll give you
everything to hit it and like we won't
talk to you like uh
and yeah we'll give you respect but we
also expect a lot back from you as well
and if that's the business for you you
have everything that we have to offer
train in our time call me 24 7. i'm
there for you professionally personally
but you've got to give back to us as
well you've got to work hard and give
that similar dedication and that's for
me like there are other businesses that
will offer different things that'll be
right for other people which is
absolutely fine like there's so many
business out there that i respect and
look up to that i wouldn't take their
employees because they're not the right
people for me and vice versa so people
we've got are very unique to what we're
building and uh i'll give them
everything for them to be successful so
what's been what's been the the strategy
then so no we we're just catching up and
you're saying going on this journey now
of um really focusing on the us and
these things but what what what's been i
guess yeah what have been like the key
things that you've been really aiming to
do and achieve this year
that yeah i guess things that you you've
done that have really helped you to
achieve what you wanted to basically so
straight away did you know that you were
going to focus on the us or the advocacy
i don't know how yeah
well even before we launched before we
launched um i had a client that never
worked with before but i knew him for a
long time um four days before i launched
he reached out to me and said i've seen
you linkedin you're not there anymore
presume you're doing your own thing
wanted to work with me for a long time
yeah um i'm willing to pay you 100 up
front for six rolls wow so i was like
literally before i even launched on that
day like
it took a took a week and a half or so
so it did get agreed after the launch
day yeah but yeah even before it
happened like we were in the us like day
one um
was that the main the main sort of part
of the plan how's the objective the
whole time yeah
right
i've been i've been working in the us
for two and a half years before right
before i started in european contracts
and then went to perm us
it's just it's a different level out
there the opportunity
for like the the quantity of roles like
the
how it's not being tapped up like you
can go in there and really seize it but
also just to share deal values
the partnerships you can create out
there
the way they work like really become an
extension of their brand whereas in
europe like i know people are doing
better stuff now and recruiters are
getting more respect but
it's it's a necessary evil i think like
people like things like that yeah like
they're like oh we we need you we don't
want you but we're gonna use you whereas
the u.s is like if they decide to
partner with you you can seriously be
like their partners like i'm in i'm in
slack channels like yesterday i went to
one of the board meetings one of our
companies so i'm fully integrated in
these teams and we don't do anything
different it's just retained recruitment
and we're going to roll out some
different models this year so year one
was all about how much money can we make
like we need to fill up this bank
account because
our next few years are going to be
reinvesting so year two now is all about
structure
we've got a pretty ambitious target um
it was actually like a five year target
initially when i've done our business
plan we're now aiming for this year uh
which we're already doesn't surprise you
yeah we already make a big dent in as
well but i don't care if we hit that or
not yeah this month i've just sort of
had so much clarity of like i don't care
if we get that it's all about structure
this year getting the right people in
the right place
so i can work on the business and not in
the business because that's what i'm
doing now like year one in the trenches
billion working 8 30 to 11 at night like
i literally gave it all last year and i
could do that again like i can build a
million a year it's like it's fine like
i can keep turning up and doing it but
where do you go from there yeah i'm
trying to put that structure in place
and promote the business be reliant on
you though exactly so i need to work on
it like i'm not really a salesman like
i'm not i'm not even the best recruiter
in the world like i'm i've i believe
i've got a very good business mind and i
know i can take this business to a whole
nother level so talk talk to me about
because people are interested talk to me
about some of the the key principles
that you feel can help people
succeed in america because as i said a
lot of people are looking at it because
a number of the reasons that you've said
but from your experience so far could be
one two three i don't know what some of
the key principles you think in getting
the american piece right so it's similar
to what we talked about in the first
question like the same attributes but i
think the thing you need to do to get it
right is dedicate yourself okay if
you're going to try and do uk time zones
and literally switch off at half five
you're working three hours a day like
that's the only crossover you're getting
so it's like if you're going to go for
it you need you need to go for it like
i'll be honest with you about the start
of this year so last year i was working
those hours 8 30 to 11 night oh yeah
this year i've sort of took my foot off
the gas and focused on europe and worked
normally in time zone yeah and our us
side has dropped massively okay so we've
recently made the shift that our whole
team yeah half of our company is u.s
half is eu and the us half is now going
to be dedicated to the u.s time zone and
that's part of getting that structure
right now and we will be open in the u.s
but it's going to be dubai first next
year and then we're going to be going to
miami after okay so it's like why miami
um easier time zone
so la was really tough to communicate
with the uk team really she had an hour
crossover okay so i don't want a team to
be in la and me not to have hardly any
communication with them sure so miami's
five hour time zone much much more
manageable and it's still a nice place
like you still get the benefits of the
sunshine the lifestyle because really
these these offices open and are purely
talent attraction it's it's not business
related at all like i'm not going there
to liaise with clients like we're going
there so we can put amazing recruiters
there and they will continue working
with clients across the globe
okay so what what are some of the things
then just thinking of people that
like are on this journey or thinking
about and i guess want some insight into
like i know you were saying like
literally just treat it the same but
some people may be skeptical about that
because yes different culture different
people yeah um but i guess what do you
think besides the hard work the
dedication what are some of the things
you think that you you guys have done
well to to really start building great
attractions relationship building okay
but again i do that in the uk which i
think is always a part in europe like
we've got wicked relations to our
clients in europe but i think
you need it in the u.s where like in the
uk like it's a necessary evil that even
if you haven't got the best relationship
they'll probably still work with you
whereas in the us like it's a must-have
and that that's not to mean like
you're chatting about their day and
getting to know about them and their
family you're gonna have to deal with
that but you just have to be
a lot more long-term think with them
find out about the business problems and
how you can add value and what they'll
be like
yeah like what weight can you take off
them like what solution can you provide
them yeah but it sounds crazy saying
that's like a us fixes you should be
doing that in europe if you're not
you're missing a trick
because people have this illusion as
well that the us is this massive market
where you're going to become a big
billow and you're content in europe like
i build just as much in europe as i do
in u.s but there's no difference between
the two it's just opportunities it's
just the opportunities in the us to go
and build those relationships but on the
other spectrum if you do that in the u.s
and bring that back to the eu you'll do
weekly as well in the eu as well
so it is true then because the common
things that we've heard is the the fees
are typically larger
the the um the obviously perception of a
recruitment consultant or a headhunter
whatever is is a lot better yeah and
obviously these things can just
massively help if you're really good at
your craft you can deliver and these
things yeah and you've got to be a good
guy i think the two attributes to make a
good recruiter is money hungry and a
good person if you're if you're money
hungry without being a good person you
won't get very far because you'll get
caught out early on you won't build the
relationships and if you're just a good
person without any money desire like you
won't push enough to make the money so
you need the combination of both yeah
yeah fair enough what just quickly
because it's a big place right have you
have you tried to focus on like a
particular state or have you been quite
open like what how how is that sort of
so pretty
we did
like that's when we moved to la like we
did try and focus on new york and san
fran okay because we could monopolize
the markets really easy like you you get
the five six best companies in that
state and then your last family yeah you
find you find the person and you you
you you don't even have to ask for
exclusivity like you you get them out to
all the best places you're placing them
okay whereas now like
the whole thing with distributed teams
going remote it's given more opportunity
but it's made things harder
in terms of light so you could be
working a company in new york but now
they could be hiring in other people in
other states whereas before i'll write
yeah yeah so it's a good thing that
opens teleport but it's a hard thing
because it opens the teleport too much
yeah yeah because yeah because it could
be quite hard to where to focus your
time to focus that area yeah so we
yeah there's no real focus the focus is
the us so we have a us team uh with a
split heavily on the us but then also um
two people dedicated to canada and then
if one person dedicated to south america
but heavy is the us and he's got to get
as much coverage as possible but yeah
it's a big place and that's what will be
our biggest team
so couple of things before we finish
then so what people always interested
what what sort of um
piece of technology and things like have
you invested in that have helped on on
the journey with the american peace yeah
hardly any
yeah i don't know that's probably the
opposite on some people here but fair
yeah i don't i don't that's also good i
just don't believe in automating stuff
it's like it's a people business like
the whole idea of you matter is putting
people back at the center okay and
having things automated or outsourcing
things i don't think does any good um
obviously i use ventura like i hate crms
i always have yeah and that's the best
job i've ever used and we utilize it um
but yeah for me like i don't invest in
tech like really yeah we just do
everything ourselves and just make sure
people are on top of it
okay that's an awful one
that's fair obviously because i think
obviously the mindset can be like you
need to have all these things
what surprised you then
so far
um two ends of the spectrum
how quick it would take off okay like we
done 250 of our target our first year i
want it to be four to six people we're
now 15 and we're not slowing down like
we're going to be
you've seen the office 34 people off
it's like that's going to be filled it's
like it's just bigger so much quicker
which has been taking a toll on me as
well because i've had to readjust i have
because how have you have you have you
managed all this like personally and
stuff because we've spoken about this
yeah because when you're spending time
with your partner if you're working
until eleven yeah like just in between
you know like and she gets it
just after you've agreed you've
communicated this is the journey that
i'm on but we know where we're going
like my personal life we know we're
going we know where the business is
going
um so yes it's been amazing how quick
it's taken off okay but the other
spectrum is how hard it is to find the
people that would be willing to do what
i've done you know like i thought when
we started this before sweet we'll just
find loads of me's
and like loads of ch and i know they
exist and like when i speak to people
it's like you can't expect people to do
what you've done yeah for your own
business no no no but i've done this to
other people i've done this when i was
an estate agency when i was in real
estate when i worked
i gave my all to everything
and i'm it's hard to find the people
that are willing to give their all but i
know they exist because
charlie does it yeah jay does it for me
now yeah i got him you and done it in
dubai like they exist i guess it's got
to be a bit of a balance isn't that yeah
for me it's relying on my expectations
because to get to 30 people are you
going to have is it going to be made up
of all those people no but there's that
you've obviously got you've got to be
committed to what the minimum standard
is let's find in that bar and we uh we
let go of our first two people
yeah we grew to two people and it went
back to zero a hard decision but
circling back to
what i said about where i know where
we're going like i'm not playing in two
years ahead i'm planning 10 years ahead
yeah yeah and uh they weren't right they
just weren't right and it was a crazy
but if it was a lifestyle business
probably would have kept them because if
i had only had a two year plan i
probably would have kept them but i knew
in the grand scheme of things these guys
weren't right and
yeah six months into the business i let
go of our first two people we employed
um and we were back at zero again that's
fair enough um but because yeah i just i
have i have an expectation on people and
could i have done more for them 100
looking back on it could i have given
more could have been a better leader but
i'm on my own journey as well and i do
look back and think could i done things
differently yeah
but um
yeah i'll always protect our culture
i'll always protect
the brand we're building and the
standards we put in place and if people
don't meet them
there's no place yeah yeah there's 39 39
000 another
company they can go to so just on this
topic before we finish because i think
it's really
uh
relevant right now with
the amount of companies doing well or
hiring like how have you how have you
like you said the most most of the
people you've hired if i'm wrong have
come without experience so however you
approach getting these people up to
speed a lot of people
are thinking about that so if these two
people didn't quite work out what what's
been the mindset towards getting them up
to speed getting competent so we give a
go for training so like i spend a day
with me and like classroom based you
could say yeah
breaking down the basics like the stuff
that probably people think is so simple
like one of the first slides on our
training presentation what is
recruitment
why would you even need it i think that
comes back to like my
my understanding of how important a
belief system is because if you think
recruiters like should only earn this
amount a year or are only valuable to
this extent you're only going to go so
far yeah so from day one i want to drill
into these guys you are going to be the
most valuable
assets system so yeah we do a classroom
based go over the basics and the shadow
of my current team okay obviously when
it was just a start they shared with me
directly where i've now shadowed my
current team and i'm trying to remain
very hands-on and that's where it comes
in i've got to stop working in the
business and i've got to work on it so
it's like i try and give as much of my
time to these guys as possible so yeah
listening to their calls playing them
like telling them the feedback from it
just as much as i possibly can do really
um it's just training never stops that's
the thing like this when they pass the
probation or get up and running or go
past it doesn't stop like becca for
example is
currently leading from the front she's
top billa right now okay i'm still
giving her the most amount of training
because of it because i know she can got
so much continuously yeah
where are you going to be then you've
spoken a lot about you know where you
want to go where where we like if we
were to sit down another year two years
time where where are you going to be
then two years later we'll be in dubai
goodbye
i'm gonna go back there i'm not going
back oh okay i'm not going bad jay's
going back okay uh then we'll be in
miami in two years time yeah um open in
that office uh we'll have a lot of
structure we're gonna build a lot of our
own technology in between this time as
well build rain technology build our own
technology and uh
when it's all said and done we'll be uh
we'll be valued at a billion a billion
billion
yeah and it sounds crazy and i think
it's i think it's a little bit crazy but
when i chatted with farook
my first two weeks i broke down why i
wanted to get to 420 million okay
and he was so on board he was like yeah
sweet let's do it sounds sound secret
about believing so soon as soon as he
said like 420 is easy like cool we're
just good this is a bit dark we'll break
it down
i thought maybe i'm shooting too low so
yeah billion like we will get to a
billion
by the end of the decade mitch love it
keep doing what you're doing mate thank
you man thank you so much
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you got value from the
conversation and there was a number of
key takeaways so please don't forget to
like share and please do share your key
takeaways in the comments below if you
did have some and thanks for supporting
the show